Ici nous sommes devant une portion très importante de l'évangile des gens.
L'évangile des gens, c'est l'un des quatre évangiles qui devraient être compris par nous
comme les biographies les plus fiables de l'homme le plus important qui a jamais vécu dans l'histoire.
Pour ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'intimité avec la Bible,
ils habitent dans l'Occident suffisamment d'intimité avec la notion du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
même car les calendriers sont divisés entre avant et après la venue du Seigneur Jésus.
Ce sont les personnages les plus importants de l'histoire
et ça devrait nous pousser à nous intéresser par son histoire.
Et si nous nous laissons pousser par cet intérêt,
la première chose à faire c'est de nous demander où nous pouvons trouver une ressource fiable
pour étudier à propos du Christ.
Et donc les biographies les plus fiables sont toujours celles qui ont été écrites
par les personnes qui habitaient les plus proches,
qui ont vécu les plus proches de cette personne que nous voulons étudier.
Et notamment ces évangélistes, ces quatre évangiles,
sont ceux qui devraient être vus par nous comme les plus fiables.
Non seulement car nous, comme les chrétiens,
nous savons qu'il y a l'inspiration de Dieu qui a gouverné ces hommes
à ne pas commettre aucune erreur lorsqu'ils étaient en train d'enregistrer ce qu'ils étaient en train d'enregistrer,
mais même par une perspective naturelle,
nous savons qu'ils nous sommes devant les personnes qui étaient les plus proches du Christ
lorsqu'ils ont écrit ces biographies.
Donc l'évangile des gens, dans ce sens-là, il est particulièrement important
car nous savons que d'entre tous les disciples, il y avait un qui a reçu les surnoms
« les disciples aimés » ou « les disciples bien-aimés »,
c'est-à-dire un niveau d'intimité avec les Seins Jésus
qui va montrer que même dans cet épisode que nous sommes en train de lire,
il était récliné à la poitrine du Christ pendant que ces choses étaient en train de se passer.
C'est-à-dire que c'était ces niveaux d'intimité particuliers
que Jean avait avec le Seigneur Jésus.
Et ici, l'apôtre Jean, il est en train de nous présenter
l'enregistrement à propos du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
de sa vie, son œuvre, qui il était, quelle était sa mission.
Et donc c'est là où nous allons retrouver les ressources les plus fiables
pour comprendre qui était Jésus et quelle était son œuvre.
C'est qui est l'objectif particulier de l'évangile des gens
comparativement aux autres évangiles.
Donc Marc, je vous rappelle, son public cible était plutôt les romans
et comme les langages des romans les plus importants,
c'est des païens qui n'avaient pas un arrière-plan juif,
il ne va pas prendre beaucoup de temps à décrire, par exemple,
la généalogie du Christ, etc.
Marc, il est concis, il est dynamique,
il utilise un langage plutôt impérial.
Donc son objectif, c'est de démontrer clairement aux romans
que Christ était le roi des rois
à cause des faits qu'il a faits, à cause des enseignements
et particulièrement par la manière dont il est mort et ressuscité.
Et donc Marc, il va monter en cas pour défendre la divinité du Christ
en tant qu'il roi des rois
en démontrant de manière progressive toutes les évidences
pour que les personnes arrivent à la conclusion,
bon, devant tout ça, je ne peux pas nier
qu'il était véritablement les rois des rois,
un roi d'ordre divine.
Voilà pourquoi c'est plutôt vers la conclusion de l'évangile des marques
qui des déclarations plus explicites et ouvertes seront faites
envers la royauté divine du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Quand on pense à Matthieu et Luc,
ils auront Matthieu en public qui est plutôt les Juifs.
Donc voilà pourquoi il va travailler beaucoup avec la généalogie,
beaucoup avec les prophéties accomplies en Jésus-Christ.
Et Luc qui était plutôt en train de porter
une recherche qui a été faite de manière très diligente,
donc lui qui était disciple plutôt d'Épaule,
lui qui était sous la supervision apostolique,
mais lui-même n'était pas un apôtre.
Et donc lui, il va chercher à affirmer la foi d'une personne,
Théophile, quelqu'un qui s'était converti.
Et donc Luc, il a cet équilibre entre les évidences,
un peu comme Marc, mais aussi l'accomplissement des prophéties,
un peu comme Matthieu.
Et Jean, ce qui est le plus intéressant,
c'est que pendant que tous ces autres évangiles,
ils essayent de montrer toutes les évidences
pour progresser dans la direction de cette conclusion.
Donc inévitablement, il était les vrais messies,
les fils des dieux, les rédempteurs, les rois des rois.
Par contre, Jean, son objectif, c'est de déclarer,
dès l'ouverture, cette identité glorieuse du Christ.
Il commence en disant, au commencement était la parole,
donc la préexistence de Dieu, les fils.
La parole était Dieu, la parole était avec Dieu.
Et la parole s'est fait chère.
Donc dès le départ et pendant tout l'évangile des gens,
il démontre des déclarations ouvertes
qui prouvent le fait que Christ était notamment
les fils des dieux.
Donc cette identité glorieuse de Jésus.
Et quand on arrive au chapitre 13,
on a une transition très importante
entre les présentations des évidences
qui démontraient clairement que les Christ étaient Dieu,
Jésus, cet homme qui habitait en Galilée,
qui vient de Nazaré,
il était, dès le départ, déclaré comme les fils des dieux.
Donc Jean commence tout de suite avec les signes,
les miracles, etc.
Mais il a démontré par les miracles
et par les discours du Christ
qu'il était fils des dieux.
Et à partir du verset 13,
Christ sera présenté surtout
par l'accomplissement de sa mission principale.
Donc voilà pourquoi
tout ce qui va se passer dans cet épisode,
la chose qui va nous étonner le plus tout de suite,
c'est d'imaginer
que ces fils des dieux faits hommes
pourraient arriver à point de faire un service
comme un esclave,
de laver les pieds de ses disciples.
OK ?
C'est étonnant.
C'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
les juifs ne voulaient pas reconnaître Christ
comme les vrais fils des dieux,
les vrais messies.
Car dans leur compréhension,
il fallait qu'il soit un roi
avec toutes les célébrités,
avec ses succès temporels,
cette prospérité terrestre,
ses royaumes sur terre.
Et ils ne pouvaient pas imaginer
cet scandale
que les fils des dieux
puissent se comporter comme un esclave.
C'était scandale
comme si les fils des dieux
pourraient mourir une mort
qui pourrait être considérée
la mort d'un maudit,
quelqu'un sous la malédiction des dieux.
La pire des morts,
la mort comme un crucifié.
Et donc cet épisode,
il est étonnant de soi-même
par ce qui est en train de s'est passé
en Jésus,
roi des rois,
fils des dieux
qui lave les pieds de ses disciples.
Mais il est en train d'introduire
quelque chose
qui va représenter
un abaissement encore plus extrême
de la part du fils des dieux
car il est en train d'inaugurer
ce schéma de la passion
qui va finir à la croix.
C'est l'accomplissement des Pâques.
C'est la Pâque de toutes les Pâques.
C'est le plus important.
Donc c'est important pour nous
d'identifier tout de suite
que pour Jean,
cette identité de Jésus
en tant que fils des dieux
incarnés,
elle est particulièrement
dans sa mission
associée à la Pâque.
Donc lisons à nouveau
les versets 1 du chapitre 13.
Avant la fête des Pâques,
Jésus, sachant que son heure
était venue dépasser
de ses mondes au Père
et ayant aimé les siens
qui étaient dans les mondes,
mis au comble
à son amour pour eux.
Donc, la conception.
Il y a deux expressions ici
qui sont très importantes
en termes d'introduction
de cette douzième partie
de tout l'évangile de Luc.
Et donc, divisé en deux parties,
miracle et prédication,
et deuxième partie,
accomplissement de sa mission principale.
OK ?
Et donc ici,
Jésus,
son identité,
sa mission,
elle est d'abord et avant tout
liée à l'accomplissement
des Pâques.
Donc, c'est quoi la Pâques ?
Déjà, pour introduire la question,
la Pâques,
elle était la date
la plus importante
pour les Juifs.
Dieu a choisi
les printemps
comme les premiers mois,
les mois des nissants.
Et la Pâques,
elle a été la date
des libérations.
C'est comme si c'était
pour la France
le 14 juillet,
juillet, pardon,
où, voilà,
les jours de la nation,
les jours identitaires
principaux de cette communauté.
Comment Israël,
elle est née
en tant que nation.
Où commence
l'émancipation d'Israël ?
Donc, Israël a été
pendant 400 ans
esclave de l'Égypte.
L'Égypte était
la potence maximale
de l'époque.
Israël ne pouvait
d'aucune manière
se libérer
de cet esclavage.
Elle n'avait
aucune force
de soi-même.
Mais Dieu avait
fait une promesse
à Israël
même avant
qu'elle soit
esclave en Égypte.
Et donc,
les jours où Dieu
va vouloir
libérer son peuple,
il va donner
à ses rois
qui étaient
superpuissants
sur terre
plusieurs menaces,
plusieurs avertissements,
à nouveau,
plusieurs opportunités,
pour qu'il puisse
plier son sens
d'autorité
à l'autorité
divine,
du vrai Dieu,
pour qu'il puisse
profiter
de cette opportunité
de répentance,
de soumission à Dieu.
Par contre,
Pharaon
indoucira son cœur
et il ne veut pas
libérer Israël
pour aller adorer Dieu.
Et donc,
Dieu,
après avoir donné
beaucoup d'avertissements,
beaucoup d'opportunités
de répentance,
si vous voulez,
Dieu va manifester
qu'Israël
ou qu'Égypte
est arrivé
au comble
de sa rébellion,
de son courraide.
Et à partir de là,
il sera détruit
de manière
impitoyable.
Ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est que tout cela
va progresser
avec les dix plaies
et c'est intéressant
car Dieu,
à chaque fois,
est en train de démontrer
sa supériorité
à l'extrême
à plusieurs faux dieux
qui croyaient
l'Égypte,
mais les dieux principaux
qui croyaient l'Égypte,
c'était Pharaon lui-même
et notamment
sa descendance.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
Dieu,
il va dire
les jours de la libération
sont arrivés,
je viendrai
vous libérer
donc j'envoie
mon esprit
de jugement
et donc,
ce que vous allez faire
pour être préservé
dans cette situation,
c'est que vous allez
prendre
un agneau
pur,
donnant,
innocent,
sans tâche,
sans aucune imperfection.
Vous allez passer
quatre jours
avec lui
pour avoir
un espèce
de niveau
d'intimité
quelque part
pour qu'il puisse
assimiler
l'innocence
de cet animal
et après quatre jours,
vous allez
l'immoler,
le sacrifier
et la nuit,
vous allez
le manger
ensemble
dans un cadre
de repas
cérémoniels
assez important
dans ses détails.
On n'a pas le temps
de rentrer
dans tous les détails,
mais il fallait
surtout prendre
de son sang
et passer
sur les poteaux
de la porte.
Et le message,
il est très important
à partir de là,
c'est Dieu
dans sa grâce
depuis la chute
de l'humanité
en Genèse,
notre race
qui n'a pas besoin
d'avoir beaucoup
d'arguments
pour être convaincu
que nous sommes
une race échouée,
une race qui ne vit
même pas à la hauteur
de notre propre conscience,
une race qui a taché
l'histoire
avec toutes les guerres
et qui est incapable
même d'aimer
ceux qui habitent
les plus proches
de nous,
notre propre famille.
On n'est jamais
à la hauteur
de notre conscience.
Et donc,
nous savons très bien
que si jamais
les paramètres
des jugements
des dieux
ne sont pas
tout simplement
la manière
dont on compare
nos vies
avec les autres,
avec les pires
qu'en nous,
mais si les paramètres
pour juger
notre innocence
sont Dieu lui-même,
la pureté absolue,
nous savons
que nous sommes
tous condamnés.
Et donc,
même lorsqu'il est Dieu
dans sa patience,
il veut pourvoir
une manière
de nous pardonner,
son pardon
ne peut jamais
fonctionner
sans que Dieu
se justifie
soi-même
devant ses exigences
de justice.
C'est-à-dire,
si nous voulons
profiter
du pardon
de Dieu,
nous devons
embrasser
la manière
juste
dont il
pourvoie
ses pardons.
Quelle est la leçon
des Pâques ?
C'est que,
même pas
en Israël,
on pourrait
trouver
une seule personne
qui serait
digne
de se tenir
devant la présence
d'un Dieu
qui vient
visiter la terre
et qui est
100% pur.
Et donc,
je viens
car
ma patience
envers
Pharaon
est arrivée
au comble.
Par contre,
si je viens,
personne ne peut
se tenir vivant.
Si pour
recevoir
mon pardon
ou être
préservé
par ma proximité
ou ma présence,
il faut
notamment
profiter
de mon moyen
ou ma provision
pour justifier
votre préservation.
Pour être plus clair,
l'Esprit
de Dieu
vient visiter
et Israël
ne peut
qu'être
préservé
car elle a
pris
un innocent
à sa place,
cet agneau,
elle a pris
de son sang
ses couverts
de ça
en disant
son innocence
me couvre
donc Dieu,
je suis purifié
par les mérites
de son innocence.
Et Dieu,
tu n'as pas besoin
de m'exterminer
car cet animal
a souffert
à ma place
la punition
que je méritais.
C'est clair
que pour Israël
à cet état
ce n'était pas
très clair
mais c'est clair
que pour nous
aujourd'hui
c'est très très clair.
On sait très bien
que les saints
des animaux
n'ont pas la capacité
d'expier
effectivement
nos coupabilités
et que leur innocence
n'est pas la vie
parfaite
qu'on devrait vivre.
Et notamment
c'est Jésus-là,
les Christ,
il était en train
d'accomplir.
Donc pour la première fois
on est devant
la seule personne
qui est véritablement
innocente
et dont la valeur
est capable
de servir
comme crédit
pour tous les êtres humains
qui seraient associés
par lui,
qui exprimeraient
cette foi.
Et donc cette foi
a été exprimée
par Israël
par la participation
de la Pâque.
Et donc la Pâque
elle était
la date la plus importante,
la célébration
de la Pâque
toutes les années
et pendant
tous ces temps-là,
plus ou moins
1400 ans
jusqu'à la venue
du Christ,
toutes les années
Israël
célébrait
cette Pâque.
Et donc ici
nous sommes devant
l'accomplissement
de la vraie
signification
des Pâques.
On est devant
un Jésus
qui donnera
du sens
à la Pâque.
mais ce qui est
intéressant à remarquer
c'est que l'accomplissement
de cette Pâque
par Christ
elle représente aussi
et surtout
la manifestation
de l'amour
de Dieu
envers
les siens
à l'extrême.
Donc le verset 1
il dit
en ayant aimé
les siens
qui étaient dans
les mondes
il les a aimés
jusqu'à l'extrême
jusqu'au bout
où il a mis
au comble
ou mis les combles
à son amour
pour eux.
Et donc
la première chose
qu'on doit comprendre
c'est que Dieu
il a
une nécessité
en tant que Dieu.
Donc Dieu
il a un niveau
de perfection morale
absolue
il est
tellement
absolument pur
et positivement pur
dans quel sens
un peu comme
les soleils.
Car peu importe
si on voulait
se sentir
mieux traité
par les soleils
et qu'on aimerait
avoir
une proximité
inappropriée
du soleil
si on n'est pas
de la même nature
du soleil
on ne peut pas
s'approcher
de lui.
Le plus on s'approche
le plus on sera
tous pulvérisés
complètement bullés.
C'est ça la sainteté
absolue
de Dieu.
Même les anges
doivent couvrir
leur visage
même en étant
moralement parfait
car Dieu
est d'une pureté
absolue.
Et voilà pourquoi
la tendance
des êtres humains
non régénérés
notre comportement
avant la confession
mon comportement
c'était de vouloir
éviter de trop
m'approcher
des dieux
car je connaissais
qu'au fond
de mon cœur
la raison principale
c'était
pour que sa lumière
n'expose pas trop
ma culpabilité
mes imperfections.
Et donc
la lumière
est venue au monde
mais les fils
des hommes
ont préféré
les ténèbres
que la lumière.
Et donc
Jésus-Christ
il représente
cette incarnation
de soleil
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que quand on voit
ces besoins
dans l'être
des dieux
cette nécessité
cet attribut
naturel des dieux
sa santé
absolue
c'est même
impossible
d'imaginer
qu'il pourrait
agir différemment
envers l'humanité.
Même nous
nous avons
en sens des justices
que si on verrait
un pédophile
qui a été
pris en flagrant
et un juge
qui va dire
je vais à l'absoudre
je les laisse
partir
sans souffrir
aucune peine
nous allons
tous juger
ces juges
non comme
quel juge bon
mais on va dire
c'est un juge
injuste.
Cette personne
mérite
les mépris
cette personne
mérite
la punition
elle représente
un danger
et elle devrait
être vue
par la société
comme quelqu'un
d'abominable.
Donc ce sens
de justice
fait partie
de nous tous
et bien sûr
que ça
ne peut
qu'évenir
même si
corrompt
en nous
ça ne peut
qu'évenir
des restes
de l'image
de Dieu
de la moralité
absolue
de Dieu
qu'il a mis
dans nos cœurs.
Et donc la réalité
c'est que Dieu
étant absolument
sans
il ne peut
faire autre
chose
que de donner
les justes
jugements
la juste
punition
qu'on mérite
et comme
nos transgressions
sont comparativement
jugées
à la mesure
de la dignité
des dieux
à qui on devrait
honorer
l'amour
qu'on devrait
honorer
et l'autorité
suprême
qu'il est
la seule manière
d'être puni
à la hauteur
de nos transgressions
c'est de passer
une éternité
à l'enfer.
C'est comme ça
que la Bible
explique la question
du jugement.
Dieu a donc
cette nécessité
et voilà pourquoi
la Pâque montre
qu'il même
Israël
qui était quelque part
la nation
qui devrait être
vue comme
la plus sainte
elle n'est pas
suffisamment sainte
pour supporter
la visitation
de Dieu
et elle a besoin
du sang
de ces animaux
qui représentaient
bien sûr
les saints du Christ
plus tard.
Mais Dieu
n'avait pas
qu'en lui
les demandes
naturelles
de sa justice
qui l'oblige
à punir
comme il faut
les péchés.
Justice
c'est inébranlable
c'est de donner
à chacun
ce qu'il est dû
et il n'y aura
aucune échappatoire
pour reconnaître
au moins
de vouloir imaginer
que Dieu n'est pas
si juste
ou si sans
car la justice
de Dieu
est comme les montagnes
inébranlables
comme l'Epsomiste
l'a dit
sauf qu'heureusement
en Dieu
on a vu
non seulement
la manifestation
de sa justice
mais aussi
la manifestation
de son amour
gracieux.
La Pâque
était une manière
de Dieu
de communiquer
à Israël
et à travers
Israël
toutes les nations
que Dieu
avait pourvue
par la motivation
exclusive
de son amour
à l'extrême
une manière
de nous réconcilier
avec lui.
Dieu a aimé
les mondes
d'une telle manière
qu'il a donné
son fils
unique.
Pourquoi ?
Car quelqu'un d'autre
devrait pourvoir
la justice
qu'on n'arrive pas
à présenter
devant Dieu
et souffrir
la punition
que nous tous
méritions.
Donc
lorsqu'on pense
à Pâques
à Jésus
lorsqu'on pense
à cette transition
de l'évangile
des marques
de toute la première
partie
envers
l'accomplissement
de sa mission
principale
nous sommes
en train
de penser
à l'amplification
des lents
des dieux
envers
la manifestation
à l'extrême
de son amour.
C'est par amour
que Dieu pourvoit
une opportunité
de rédemption
car si c'était
basé par justice
on serait tous
à l'enfer.
Et donc
ce texte va mettre
en lumière
que cet épisode
des lave-pieds
est une manifestation
extrême
d'amour
mais c'est une manifestation
extrême d'amour
qui est en train
de déclencher
la manifestation
encore plus extrême
d'amour des dieux
qui est la rédemption.
C'est intéressant
de remarquer
par les constats
des gens.
Il dit le suivant
en ayant aimé
les siens
qui étaient
dans les mondes
il les a aimés
jusqu'à l'extrême.
Et ça c'est la question
qu'on devrait tous
se poser dans nos cœurs.
Quelle est la perspective
que nous avons
du Christ ?
Quelqu'un qui pourrait
améliorer légèrement
nos vies
qui pourrait favoriser
nos circonstances
temporelles ?
Est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui pourrait
tout simplement
nous guérir ?
Qu'est-ce qui ressortait
le plus
de ces trois années
que Jean avait vécu
avec les Christ
dans toute cette proximité ?
Quel est le niveau
de proximité
que vous avez
avec les Christ
et qu'est-ce qui ressort
le plus
de votre expérience
avec Christ ?
Il me fait du bien,
il me réconforte
ou la somme
de tout ce que Christ
représente pour vous
dans votre relation
avec Jésus
veut signifier
ces constats.
Et les constats
sont celles-ci
en ayant aimé
ce qui était
les siens
dans les mondes.
C'est-à-dire
les siens
dans ces passages
n'est pas les siens
du premier chapitre.
Il est venu
pour les siens
mais les siens
ne lui ont pas
reconnu.
Dans les premiers chapitres
les siens
c'est plutôt
les juifs.
Il est venu
pour accomplir
les prophéties juives
mais les juifs
n'ont pas reconnu
car ils étaient attachés
à l'amour
de ces mondes.
Ici les siens
c'est vraiment
les siens.
Ce sont ceux
qui par la foi
se sont associés
avec lui
et qui ont
cette relation
des proximités
avec lui.
Dans ces contextes
c'était les disciples
qui marchaient
avec lui.
Et les constats
principaux
c'est pas comme
si Jésus
était quelqu'un
de menaçant
en attendant
la prochaine chute
pour nous virer.
Pour nous chasser.
C'était pas
quelqu'un
qu'on devrait
chercher à plaire
afin d'être béni.
C'était pas
quelqu'un
qu'on pourrait
s'associer
pour avoir
quelques avantages
politiques
comme c'était
le cas
pour Judas
les traîtres.
Jésus
il était
celui
qui les aimait.
Une profonde
conviction
du fait
que pendant
ces trois années
personne
n'avait aimé
Jean
plus que
le Christ.
Personne
n'avait
un niveau
d'intimité
avec Jean
plus intime
que Christ.
il avait
la compréhension
que même
ma mère
mon épouse
ou mes enfants
n'ont pas
ces mêmes niveaux
d'amour
ou d'intimité
avec moi.
Et Jean
qui était
complètement
convaincu
de cette
association
d'amour
de la part
du Seigneur
Jésus
envers lui
il s'est
divisé
que cet
amour
en continu
était
particulièrement
manifesté
comme à l'extrême
à partir
des choses
qui vont se
passer
à partir
de cette
cérémonie
de lave-pied
et vers
la crucifixion.
Et donc
ce texte
il met en évidence
la sublime
dignité
ou amabilité
du Christ
qui est révélée
particulièrement
par
l'accomplissement
de son office
sacerdotal.
Et donc
quelle est la notion
biblique des prêtres ?
Avec la notion
des sacrifices
Dieu dans sa grâce
a donné
beaucoup de règles
pour les tabernacles
pour la Pâque
et la médiation
était faite
par un homme
qui était séparé
d'entre les hommes
donc le langage
d'hébreu
pour nous faire
comprendre
les prêtres
ils étaient séparés
d'entre les hommes
par Dieu
pour représenter
les hommes
dans des choses
concernantes à Dieu.
Donc des personnes
qui étaient séparées
pour être sanctifiées
d'une manière particulière
ce qui est en parallèle
pour les ministres
les pasteurs
bibliques
au moins
mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ces hommes
devraient mener une vie
de totale séparation
et entre eux
il y avait enquêté
les suprêmes
sacrificateurs
et une fois par année
il allait
célébrer l'expiation
et il serait
les responsables
principaux
de la célébration
des Pâques
du sacrifice
des animaux
pour la Pâque.
et donc
Christ
à partir de ce moment
il sera en train
de manifester
avant toute autre chose
non plus
son identité
ou son rôle
en tant que prophète
en tant que roi
mais en tant que
suprême
sacrificateur
et c'est glorieux
de considérer
que cette manière
d'exercer
ses rôles particuliers
était une expression
de son amour
à l'extrême
et donc
cet amour à l'extrême
signifie un amour
jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'à la dernière minute
de sa vie
mais c'est surtout
un niveau qualitatif
c'est de manifester
un amour
à l'extrême
et la question pour nous
c'est de tout simplement
contempler et pointer
quelques facettes
glorieuses
de cet amour
de cette excellence
à l'extrême
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
donc les versets
il va
nous introduire
à l'extrême
excellence
de l'identité
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
en tant que
notre grand prêtre
et donc
ce qui fait
du Seigneur Jésus
excellent
pour ce qui est révélé
à nous
dans sa parole
de quelle manière
l'Épac
enrichisse
notre compréhension
de la gloire
de la beauté
de la totale
amabilité du Christ
c'est car
elle nous permet
dans ses passages
de contempler
la conscience
que le Seigneur Jésus Christ
avait de son identité
de qui il était
et par la contemplation
de l'identité
de la dignité
de la personne
de celui
qui nous a aimés
à l'extrême
ça devrait
pulvériser
toutes sortes
des manques
d'assurance
de soi
une espèce
on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui
des développements
personnels
et tout cela
est enraciné
dans une espèce
de valeur
très personnelle
qu'on doit trouver
en nous-mêmes
qui reste
trop égocentrique
qui nous force
à faire
qu'il y ait
des bonnes affirmations
envers nous-mêmes
en attendant
de partir
envers ces mondes
de manière plus rassurée
et parfois même
d'obliger aux personnes
de se traiter
les unes aux autres
en oubliant
complètement ces manquements
pour suggérer
que nous avons tous
de la valeur
et bien sûr
que nous avons tous
de la valeur
qui reste de l'image
de Dieu
mais bien sûr
que nous avons tous
beaucoup de fautes
qu'on devrait reconnaître
les chrétiens
il est le seul
qui a des raisons
objectives
et fondées
dans la vérité
pour pouvoir
assumer
véritablement
ces fautes
et ces manquements
mais ne pas
se laisser
décourager
à l'extrême
par ça
car le même Jésus
qui a révélé
notre humiliation
c'est celui
qui nous a
rélevé
avec lui
donc l'identité
du chrétien
elle est enracinée
dans l'identité
de celui
qui nous a aimé
car à la fin des comptes
les choses
qui nous ébranlent
les plus
en termes
de confiance
de soi
ou assurance
si vous voulez
ça dépend
beaucoup
de qui sont
les personnes
les plus importantes
pour nous
et quelle est
la valeur
qu'elles nous donnent
c'est de ne pas
vouloir décevoir
mon père
ou ma mère
et l'importance
que mon père
et ma mère
me rassurent
de leur amour
si je suis toujours
dans la dépendance
et me sentir
menacé
si jamais
je manque ici
ou si je ne fais
pas les choses
comme ma mère
ou mon père
attendez-moi
peut-être
qu'il ne va pas
m'aimer
à l'extrême
vous comprenez ?
par contre
la dignité
suprême
c'est la dignité
des dieux
la dignité
du Christ
et si
on comprend
qui est la personne
la plus importante
de l'univers
par rapport
à qui
la vie
importe
nous aime
à l'extrême
nous sommes
prêts
à tout
nous pouvons
tout supporter
nous n'avons plus
raison
de vouloir
nous autopréserver
nous autopromouvoir
dépendre des éloges
et des avis
des certains
car notre identité
est profondément
associée
à celle du Christ
et c'est notamment
de cette manière
que Christ manifeste
la richesse
de son identité
verset 13
avant la fête
des Pâques
Jésus
sachant
que son heure
était venue
donc attention
dans quelles circonstances
quelqu'un manifeste
cette assurance
de soi
l'assurance de soi
il n'y a qu'est Christ
qui peut avoir
car nous ne pouvons pas
nous assurer
de nous-mêmes
mais dans quelles circonstances
nous manifestons
clairement
notre faiblesse
c'est particulièrement
les moments
où on se sent méprisé
particulièrement
les moments
où on ne nous traite pas
comme il faut
particulièrement
les moments
où on est sous menace
notre fragilité
Christ savait
qu'il allait être trahi
il savait
qu'il serait la Pâque
qu'il serait crucifié
qu'il serait rejeté
par son peuple
il savait
qu'il allait faire face
à la mort
son heure
était venue
de partir
de ses cosmos
par contre
malgré
ces circonstances
il ne va pas
assumer une posture
de victimisation
il ne va pas
chercher
à se défendre
il va
notamment
comprendre
quelle est sa mission
et il va trouver
des motivations
dans son identité
pour accomplir
ce qu'il faut
et donc
regardez bien
sachant que son heure
était venue
de passer
de ces mondes
au Père
donc attention
qui est
ce Christ
est celui
qui est
les pré-existants
il n'est pas
en train
de passer
de ces mondes
à l'avenir
pour lui
la gloire
n'était pas
l'avenir
la gloire
était son
lieu d'origine
des procédences
il était en train
de retourner
au Père
sa provenance
était divine
il était en train
de retourner
à la gloire céleste
et ce qui est
le plus intéressant
c'est que
quand Christ
il pense
à la gloire céleste
il n'est pas
en train
de décrire
la gloire céleste
comme
cet endroit
glorieux
où on pourra
imaginer
tous les conforts
toute la richesse
plus besoin
d'hôpitaux
des policiers
plus besoin
d'un système
de justice
car tout sera
restauré
vivre avec la nature
glorifier
les animaux
la beauté
réjouir
des bonnes choses
de cette vie
tout cela est vrai
par rapport
à la gloire future
mais tout cela
n'est qu'en train
d'adorner
ce qui représente
le mieux
je disais
à mes enfants
cette semaine
si des fois
ils ont une journée
difficile
à l'école
peut-être que
pendant plusieurs moments
dans leur journée
à l'école
ils ont pu
avoir désiré
les bras
de son père
ou de sa mère
peut-être qu'il a souffert
en bullying
quelqu'un n'a pas
laissé jouer
il pense
tout de suite
si ma mère
était ici
si mon père
ensuite
il a exposé
des mauvais enseignements
combien j'aimerais
que ma mère
ou mon père
soient ici
pour me protéger
pour débattre
après
il peut avoir
fait des bêtises
et être mis au coin
peut-être qu'il a désiré
qu'on soit là aussi
peut-être qu'il a eu fain
que la nourriture
à l'école
n'était pas bonne
et qu'il aurait
tellement
à être à la maison
pour réduire
des bons
conforts
des choses
et peu importe
quelles soient
les difficultés
qu'il a traversées
la pensée
qui devrait se répéter
dans sa tête
c'est
combien mieux
ce sont les bras
de mon père
et de ma mère
et quand il est
un chemin de la maison
il n'est pas
il n'y a aucune autre chose
qui devrait occuper
sa pensée
et ce n'est pas
c'est jouer
ce n'est pas la bonne
nourriture
mais c'est notamment
revenir au père
revenir
à la mère
vous comprenez ?
dans la perspective
du Christ
dont la gloire
est si glorieuse
car nous
attention
ni les yeux
ont vu
ni les oreilles
entendues
ce que Dieu
est en train
de préparer
pour ceux
qu'il aime
par contre
Christ
avait vu
il était
asservi
des anges
il était
l'objet
de l'adoration
des anges
et l'objet
de toutes
les affections
du père
et donc
quelque part
pour nous
c'est très difficile
de sortir
de ce cosmos
de ce monde
de cet univers
on contemple
la beauté
des étoiles
on contemple
la beauté
et les bonnes
expériences
de cette vie
on aime bien
bien manger
et même
les relations
mais pour Christ
et même
les choses dures
de cette vie
pour nous
c'est dur
à supporter
mais imaginez
pour les Christ
rien
qui est d'avoir
incarné
d'habiter
dans ces corps
qui est en train
de se détériorer
d'éveillir
ces corps
qui souffrent
vous imaginez
les dieux
omniprésents
éternels
confinés
encore moins
et en souffrant
et sachant
qu'il va bientôt
souffrir
la mort
des crucifixions
par contre
il connaissait
sa procédence
d'où je viens
où je vais
quelle est ma procédence
quelle est mon identité
même si tous
ici devant moi
vont me mépriser
vont me faire souffrir
je sais
que je serai bientôt
c'est un tunnel
que je dois traverser
difficile
mais en même temps
c'est un moyen
nécessaire
pour que je sois
à nouveau
à la maison
personne n'a vu Dieu
sa procédence
à fortifier
le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
pour au lieu
de se sentir
trop menacé
par les chemins
durs
de sa passion
pour accomplir
les Pâques
cela l'a motivé
à avancer
et c'est toi
il nous dit encore
Jésus
qui savait
que les Pères
avaient rémis
toutes les choses
en saiment
qu'il était venu
des dieux
et qu'il s'en allait
à Dieu
et donc
le texte continue
en disant
il s'est
léva de la table
ôta ses vêtements
pris en linge
dont il s'est saigné
et ensuite versa
de l'eau
dans un bassin
et il s'est mis
à laver les pieds
des disciples
et les essuyer
avec les langes
dont il était sans
donc qu'est-ce
qui a donné
à Christ
la force
la motivation
pour faire
les services
d'un esclave
et pour aller
jusqu'à la mort
des croix
c'était avant tout
la conscience
qu'il venait du Père
il revenait au Père
il venait des dieux
il retournait
à Dieu
il était conscient
de son heure
donc à nouveau
ça c'est très important
car des fois
Christ nous est présenté
tout simplement
comme un bon exemple
la croix
nous est présenté
comme la pire
des trajets
des humains
comme si
c'était
circonstanciel
les faits
que Christ
finisse à la croix
à l'heure
où il a fini
à la croix
pendant les Pâques
et la réalité
c'est que Christ
il connaissait très bien
son heure
le chapitre précédent
nous montre clairement
que lui
dans un moment donné
il était sous persécution
il va échapper
maintenant
il va tout faire
pour que les timings
dans la chronologie
des dieux
se passent
de manière
à la minute
en conformité
avec les plans
des rédemptions
des dieux
il va faire avancer
sa mort à la croix
il va volontairement
marcher dans sa direction
c'est lui
qui est au contrôle
donc Dieu
avait remis
toutes les choses
entre ses mains
donc il sait très bien
qu'à travers
ce rébaissement
et cette mort
des croix
il sera rélevé
par son ascension
et résurrection
là
sa présence
donc
celui
de suprême
dignité
a manifesté
la richesse
de son caractère
en faisant
ses services
si généreux
comme les services
d'un esclave
qui lave nos pieds
vous comprenez
qui montre vraiment
la richesse
son caractère
c'est lui
qui exige
les services
ou c'est lui
qui montre
qu'il est tellement
riche en dignité
qu'il peut même
faire le travail
d'un esclave
prochaine question
l'auteur de la vie
n'a pas pu
être découragé
par la mort
et la mort des croix
car il savait
que la mort
ne pouvait pas
les tenir
et donc
le Seigneur Jésus
il va avancer
sur cette base
certains d'entre nous
ont déjà eu
le privilège
de traverser
l'expérience
que la Bible
peut décrire
comme
un réveil
une visitation
de Saint-Esprit
un déversement
nous sommes tous
qui sont chrétiens
habités par
le Saint-Esprit
mais certains d'entre nous
ont déjà eu
une expérience
similaire à celle
que Christ a eue
deux fois dans sa vie
la première
au baptême
voici mon fils
bien-aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
la deuxième
à la transfiguration
il va entendre
la même chose
c'est-à-dire
même Christ
qui avait
ces niveaux
d'intimité
avec Dieu
il a eu
des moments
extraordinaires
des visitations
de Saint-Esprit
des déclarations
de Père
des convictions
de cet amour
intime
et particulier
certains vont appeler ça
les baptêmes
avec les Saint-Esprit
mais je pense
que garder
le langage du réveil
est le plus utile
pour nous aujourd'hui
et la réalité
c'est que plusieurs hommes
dans l'histoire
de l'Église
ont vécu cette réalité
Jean Calvin
la description
incroyable
mais il y a un homme
qui s'appelle
John Flavel
d'entre les puritans
et c'est incroyable
la description
notamment pour ce
qui est lié
à ces passages
il était tellement
convaincu
d'être aimé
personnellement
par l'amour
à l'extrême
des dieux
et du Christ
en ayant la compréhension
de sa totale amabilité
de sa totale dignité
qui est celui
qui m'aime
et à quel niveau
il mène
et il a eu
cette expérience
de manière intime
expérimentale
et profonde
et l'une des choses
qu'il dit
c'est que dans cette expérience
pour la première fois
il a regardé
la mort
comme en ayant
un visage
aimable
favorable
les réalités célestes
elles étaient
devenues
tellement plus concrètes
que cette vie
qu'il avait même
oublié
dans un certain moment
de ce qu'il pourrait
laisser derrière
pour la première fois
il a pu
raisonner avec
l'apôtre Paul
quand il dit
où est mort
ta victoire
ton aiguillon
car si notre identité
est associée
à l'identité
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
ce qui est vrai
pour lui
est vrai pour nous
et nous allons
sortir de cette terre
et nous allons partir
envers la maison
et au sein
de cette maison
il y a les pères
qui veulent
nous accueillir
sous ses ailes
voilà pourquoi
les chrétiens
devraient
manifester
une vie similaire
à celle du Christ
si notre identité
est enracinée
dans l'identité
du Christ
nous sommes libres
pour aimer
à l'extrême
nous sommes libres
pour faire les services
d'un esclave
nous sommes libres
pour faire face
à l'opposition
afin de faire avancer
les saluts
des perdus
prendre notre croix
et suivre les Christ
a tout à voir
avec la mesure
dont nous nous sentons
aimés
par Jésus
notre difficulté
à agir
comme un esclave
entre les frères
et envers les perdus
a tout à voir
avec notre mauvaise
compréhension
de l'évangile
et la mauvaise
expérience
ressentie
de l'amour
du Christ
envers nous
c'est une crise
d'identité
Christ
nous a détrôné
en tant que roi
de notre égoïsme
pour faire de nous
des princes
et princesses
esclaves
les uns
des autres
et un autre aspect
de cette excellence
du Christ
que j'aimerais voir
avec vous
aujourd'hui
c'est ces modèles
incroyables
de comment
conduire
les disciples
c'est-à-dire
un modèle
de comment
nous devrions
être
et représenter
les uns
pour les autres
les prêtres
les sacerdotes
universels
c'est une doctrine
défendue
par les réformés
car
ces modèles
dont Christ
il a présenté
cette manière
d'agir
ces lave-pieds
représentés
pour Christ
et pour les disciples
non seulement
et surtout
avant tout
la manière
dont ces leaders
devaient agir
mais ce qui était
attendu
de tous ceux
qui réclament
être associés
à Christ
donc l'excellence
du Christ
attention
elle est révélée
dans ces passages
par la manière
dont il est
un leader
dont il sert
ses prochains
ok
et donc
ces passages
il a plusieurs niveaux
des leçons
ce que je vous fais
maintenant
vous ne comprenez pas trop
par contre
Jean il est en train
de nous donner
des pistes déjà
c'est lié à la Pâque
c'est lié
à tout ce qui va se passer
après
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
Jésus va faire
son discours
des farewells
des
comment dire
d'au revoir
son discours
des départs
ok
dans les cénacles
dans la chambre haute
il va
ensuite
prier
avec les disciples
et passer
par les Gethsémanis
vous vous rappelez
cette prière
presque des consécrations
envers la croix
et ensuite
la crucifixion
donc il va
faire la prière
sacerdotale
tout ça
dans cette période
c'est-à-dire
il est en train
de déclencher
par les lave-pieds
quelque chose
de signification
profonde
spirituelle
théologique
ok
par contre
ça reste quand même
la leçon
immédiate
et la leçon
c'est
de quelle manière
un leader
chrétien
se porte
devant la communauté
et de quelle manière
la communauté
devrait reproduire
les modèles
qu'il devrait
voir
dans les leaders
chrétiens
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc
Jésus
il vient
pendant le souper
lorsque les diables
avaient déjà
inspiré
au coeur
de Judas
Iscariot
fils de Simon
les descend
et les livrer
donc attention
le Seigneur
Jésus
Christ
il est très
conscient
du traitement
qu'il va
recevoir
bientôt
de l'un
de ses disciples
Judas
Iscariot
quelqu'un
qui était
reconnu
publiquement
et qui marchait
avec Jésus
pendant ses trois ans
qui était
à service
du Christ
et qui était
responsable
comme on a vu
pour les offrandes
de la gestion
même
des finances
des trésoriers
donc Christ
il savait
qu'il ne dépendait
pas
à ce niveau-là
de l'argent
qu'il a
permis
que les trésoriers
soient
quelqu'un
qu'il savait
qu'il était
en train
de dérober
et donc
le Seigneur
Jésus
malgré
la conscience
que Judas
allait
trahir
par l'épris
d'un esclave
il a quand même
assumé
cette identité
et a agi
en tant qu'esclave
jusqu'à l'extrême
jusqu'à laver
même les pieds
de celui
qu'il savait
qu'il les traiterait
comme un esclave
il savait
qu'il était
en train
d'être méprisé
à l'extrême
il savait
que d'entre
les disciples
visibles
la réalité
spirituelle
n'était pas
la même
pour tous
et pour certains
malgré
les niveaux
des privilèges
qu'ils ont
eu
d'être devant
l'homme
des dieux
qui était
les Christ
Dieu-homme
qui était
les Christ
d'avoir
reçu
ses enseignements
d'être
si proche
de son cercle
le plus intime
d'avoir reçu
tellement
des manifestations
d'amour
de la part
des dieux
envers lui
ça va
révéler
les niveaux
d'incrédulité
dans le cœur
de cet homme
et un niveau
d'incrédulité
des dépravations
des mépris
qui montrent
que parfois
ce qui manque
n'est pas
les bons enseignements
ni les bons modèles
il n'y a rien
qui manque
en Christ
pour qu'il accomplisse
sa partie
dans cette affaire
par contre
il y a
ce mystère
cette responsabilité
des Judas
dans la manière
dont il est
en train
de rejeter
dont il est
en train
de mépriser
dont il est
en train
d'afficher
qu'en réalité
Jésus n'a jamais
été les rois
de son cœur
l'argent
restait
les rois
de son cœur
la politique
restait
les rois
de son cœur
à un moment donné
il arrive
à la conclusion
récemment
Jésus
il venait
d'être reconnu
publiquement
en tant que roi
l'entrée triomphale
à Jérusalem
toute la foule
qui voulait
après bien sûr
les miracles
de la multiplication
des pains
et poissons
voilà notre roi
il va inaugurer
ses royaumes terrestres
il est déjà en train
de pouvoir
de la nourriture
avec générosité
quel roi puissant
c'est fini
avec
avec Pilate
c'est fini
avec César
et Jésus
s'est mis
à côté
pour nous rappeler
que son cètre
des royautés
n'est pas de ce monde
et que c'est surtout
par sa mort
et son ascension
qu'il va occuper
les cèdres célestes
mais Judas
en voyant
qui Christ
se retire
de cette opportunité
de devenir
les leaders politiques
il arrive
à cette conclusion
ça ne veut pas
la peine
pour moi
dans les chapitres 12
Jésus confronte
les pharisiens
la Bible dit
certains
d'entre les juifs
ont cru
mais ils n'ont pas
voulu confesser
publiquement
pour ne pas être
chassés
ou mis en dehors
des synagogues
l'attachement
à la religion
institutionnelle
comme pendant
la période catholique
corrompue
plusieurs
cherchaient
à opérer
une réforme
mais n'osaient pas
à rompre
avec la domination
de l'institution
ils sont restés
corrompus
là-dedans
comme aujourd'hui
dans les mondes
évangéliques
même certains pasteurs
ont déjà
compris
la vérité
dans des sectes
mais ils n'ont pas
le courage
de sortir
de l'institution
avec la peur
de ne pas avoir
les ressources
de ne pas pouvoir
utiliser un bâtiment
de ne pas avoir
un salaire
et ils restent
dans la corruption
c'était le cas
pour Judas
et donc Judas
il allait
mépriser
l'amour du Christ
cet amour
à l'extrême
qui va laver
son pied
par contre
!
c'est pas
que Judas
qui est
réproché
dans cet épisode
car
le texte
nous dit
que les bassins
étaient là
l'eau
était là
peut-être que
lorsque Jésus
a demandé
à l'un de ses disciples
d'aller
en avance
et demandé
à certains disciples
de préparer
les choses
les disciples
du Christ
ont perdu
un peu
la notion
du privilège
que nous avons
de servir
notre Seigneur
peut-être
qu'en se sentant
comme les apôtres
ou les disciples
il y avait
certaines tâches
qu'ils n'étaient pas
prédisposées à faire
c'était clair
que
quelques moments
avant
quelques jours
Christ a dû
réprocher
Jean
Jacques
dans ses débats
avec les disciples
qui sera
le plus grand
quand on arrivera
au paradis
qui va s'asseoir
à ta droite
à ta gauche
et Christ
démontre
que la mesure
pour les royaumes
c'est combien
nous sommes
prédisposés
à assumer
notre identité
en tant que serviteur
à souffrir
pour promouvoir
la vie des autres
à être si humble
comme les Christ
nous entendons
des discours parfois
de la théologie
de la prospérité
vous êtes des têtes
et non que
Dieu vous a fait
pour être
dans les positions
les plus élevées
de la société
vous êtes les princes
et princesses
du roi
l'eau était là
les bassins
les serviettes
ils venaient
des bétonies
ils ont marché
avec leurs sandailles
leurs pieds étaient sales
c'était la responsabilité
du hôte
dans ces occasions
des pourvoirs
des esclaves
des servants
pour laver les pieds
des personnes
et les disciples
n'ont pas été
à la hauteur
du sens des privilèges
et de la dignité
qui a eu par exemple
Abigail
devant David
dans l'Ancien Testament
qui a commencé
son discours
en disant
je n'ai pas la dignité
de laver tes pieds
devant un roi humain
devant David
elle qui était
une femme intelligente
intelligente
des positions aussi
il n'était
certainement pas
à la hauteur
de Jean-Baptiste
car lorsque Jean-Baptiste
a vu l'écrit
la première chose
qu'il a dit
je n'ai même pas
la dignité
de toucher
au sandailles
des tes pieds
en pensant
notamment
à laver
je n'ai même pas
la dignité
de laver
car je ne peux
même pas toucher
à l'endroit
le plus sale
qu'on pourrait imaginer
à propos du Christ
ils n'ont pas été
à la hauteur
des maris
des bétanées
ou pardon
Marie des bétanées
aussi
qui a nettoyé
avec ses larmes
avec les vases
d'albâtre
avec ses parfums
très chers
en démontrant
que la partie
la plus sale
de l'homme
Christ
car Christ
n'est dans aucun sens
sale au niveau
spirituel
était
beaucoup plus
cher
avait beaucoup
plus de valeur
que les parfums
les plus chers
qu'on peut trouver
dans cette terre
et la dignité
suprême
de la femme
c'était ses cheveux
elle nettoyait
les pieds
du Christ
avec ses cheveux
et Christ
il a dit
partout
où cette nouvelle
s'est racontée
l'histoire
de cette femme
s'est racontée
sa foi
avons-nous cette foi
la dignité
du Christ
et notamment
cette femme
au début du ministère
du Christ
public
qui va
venir
nettoyer ses pieds
avec ses larmes
essuyer
avec ses cheveux
les disciples
n'avaient pas
n'étaient pas
à la hauteur
de la foi
de ces personnes
les apôtres
et ces éléments
étaient comme
un témoin
silencieux
mais condamnatoire
en disant
qui d'entre vous
leur pensait
si Pierre ne fait pas
moi je ne vais pas le faire
si Jean ne fait pas
voici une opportunité
pour que nous fassions
en service
qui honorent les Christs
simple
humble
anonyme
humiliant
mais nous on se sent
très important
et des fois
il y a certaines personnes
qui arrivent
à un point
où ils disent
je ne veux pas
participer
à certaines choses
si ma position
ne sera pas reconnue
si ma contribution
ne sera pas
remercie
publiquement
certains pasteurs
ne peuvent pas
participer
à certains événements
s'ils ne sont pas
invités
à prendre la parole
!
Et nous
quand on pense
à cette préoccupation
du Christ lui-même
attention
les plus importants
viendront encore
c'est les répas
de la Pâque
c'est la crucifixion
du Christ
les plus importants
est encore à venir
mais regardez bien
l'importance
pour Christ
qu'il y ait
la préparation
soit à la hauteur
de l'événement
que les pieds
soient lavés
quand on va faire
par exemple
un culte
familial
qu'on ait
de l'ordre
dans la table
dans l'environnement
que Dieu nous protège
de cette tentation
parfois
de faire des prières
des reconnaissances
à Dieu
envers la nourriture
de manière trop pressée
sans assimiler
et sans permettre
que nos enfants
assimilent vraiment
quand on va faire
les dévotions
quand nous allons
célébrer nos cultes
l'importance
que les Sainte-Jésus-Christ
sont en train
de donner
aux anonymes
aux servicials
qui considèrent
comme
la manière
la plus élevée
d'honorer les Christs
car on ne peut jamais
faire quelque chose
sur la hauteur
de sa dignité
même les moindres choses
sont importantes
car il est digne
de tout
donc on devrait
évaluer
nous sommes devant
un culte
des Pâques
comment nous pouvons
les célébrer
à la hauteur
de ce qui représentait
la Pâque
et bien sûr
c'est férié
heureusement
mais si nous allons voyager
qu'on soit sûr
d'être dans une église
en bonne santé
afin
de célébrer la Pâque
qu'on soit soigneux
envers tous les détails
mais le plus important ici
dans ces passages
c'est de voir
que Christ
démontre
la dignité
de son leadership
par cette manière
serviciale
dont il montre
qui est notamment
car son identité
est suprême
Dieu des dieux
roi des rois
et il montre
sa richesse
notamment
non parce qu'il peut
retenir
mais parce qu'il peut
donner
et il peut donner
jusqu'à se
rébaisser
afin de promouvoir
les vies des autres
voilà pourquoi
Christ dit
si
tu ne te laisses
pas laver
tes pieds
tu n'as pas
part avec moi
si ton comportement
ne peut pas
résonner avec
les miens
dans votre traitement
de vos prochains
si tu n'es pas
prédisposé
à offrir
à d'autres
cette procédure
d'esclave
que j'ai eu
envers toi
ne pense pas
que tu sois
véritablement
connecté à moi
tu n'as pas
part avec moi
si l'humilité
ne fait pas partie
de ta manière
de vivre
et le plus important
pour conclure
c'est que
la leçon
spirituelle
derrière ça
c'est que
la chose
moindre sale
que Christ a pu faire
envers nous
c'était
de laver nos pieds
de la boue
et de la poussière
matérielle
vous ne comprenez pas
ce que je fais
maintenant
car la question
ici
n'est pas
laver vos pieds
de la matière
ça c'est un exemple
que vous devriez
tous avoir
les uns vers les autres
mais ça n'est qu'une
illustration
d'un lavage
beaucoup plus profond
voilà pourquoi
Jésus va dire
au verset 18
ce n'est pas
de vous tous
que je parle
je connais
ceux
que j'ai choisi
mais il faut
que l'écriture
s'accomplisse
et celui
qui mange
avec moi
les pains
a levé
son talon
contre moi
et voilà pourquoi
il dit
au verset 10
celui qui est déjà lavé
n'a besoin
qu'il s'est lavé
les pieds
pour être entièrement
pur
et vous êtes pur
mais non pas tous
car il connaissait
celui qui les livrait
c'est pourquoi
il dit
vous n'êtes pas
tous pur
donc la leçon
derrière
les comportements
visibles
c'est quelle est
la réalité spirituelle
et la réalité
spirituelle ici
c'est
ce lavage
est ponté
envers
un lavage
initial
radical
un banc
complet
on a
dû
être
immergé
dans ce lavage
qui représente
le Saint-Esprit
qui nous régénère
mais
les disciples
doivent être
réprochés ici
par leur manque
de prédisposition
à servir
mutuellement
donc sali
par ces mondes
l'attachement
à ces mondes
mais ils étaient
déjà lavés
ils étaient déjà
nés de nouveau
de l'autre côté
il y avait un
qui n'était pas
du tout
lavé de nouveau
vous comprenez
dans ces petits
cercles
il y avait
un homme
qui n'était
jamais
véritablement
lavé de nouveau
bien sûr
qu'il a dû
prendre ses douches
et la leçon du Christ
on n'est pas en train
de parler
de l'eau littérale
et la même chose
par rapport aux autres
vous vous êtes
tous lavés
vous avez tous
été baptisés
été nés
des nouveaux
et donc
la leçon pour nous
spirituelle ici
c'est
Christ
il est
la Nouvelle
Pascale
dans quel sens
les seuls
innocents
médiateurs
parfaits
venus des dieux
car aucun
médiateur
humain
aucun prêtre
ne pouvait
représenter
véritablement
la double nature
la nature divine
la nature humaine
cette personne
qui fait partie
éternellement
de la trinité
a pris
un corps humain
pour lui
a habité
notamment
dans un corps humain
mais c'était
toujours la même personne
c'est pas une nouvelle
personne qui apparaît
c'était celui
qui savait
qu'il venait
de Dieu
et revenait à Dieu
donc il a
cette capacité
de faire
la médiation
parfaite
entre Dieu
et homme
déjà
car il a
la double nature
aujourd'hui
on a
un Dieu
homme
ressuscité
dans les mêmes
corps
qu'il a incarné
qu'il est mort
qu'il est ressuscité
et glorifié
qui représente
l'humanité
pour la première fois
devant la présence
des dieux
et donc
étant Dieu
et homme
Christ nous réconcilie
parfaitement
avec Dieu
il est qualifié
pour être
ses médiateurs
en même temps
il est qualifié
non seulement
par son être
cette double nature
mais il est qualifié
aussi car il accomplit
ce qu'il faut
il a incarné
pour pouvoir
représenter
effectivement
car les animaux
ne peuvent pas
faire ça
effectivement
en tant qu'être
humain
vivre la loi
parfaitement
à notre place
vivre la vie
d'amour
qu'on n'arrive
pas à vivre
aimer Dieu
sur toute autre chose
et les prochains
comme soi-même
nous aimer
jusqu'à l'extrême
il l'a fait
et il a aussi
souffert la punition
donc l'agneau
sans tâche
parfait
représente
l'innocence
du Christ
et les sacrifices
les 100 versets
c'est la crucifixion
du Christ
et ce que Christ
est en train de nous rappeler
c'est qu'il est
non seulement
l'auteur
de notre foi
mais il est celui
qui va prendre soin
de nous
jusqu'à la fin
et qui nous devons
progressivement
et continuellement
venir à la table
du Seigneur
par exemple
pour
laver nos pieds
baptême
en banc entier
donc bien sûr
symbologie
les baptêmes
représentent
les lavages
spirituels
intérieurs
la sainte scène
représente
nous revenons
constamment
à Christ
pour nous nourrir
constamment
de lui
la doctrine
principale
ici
c'est celle
qu'on appelle
l'union
avec Christ
cette union
légale
dans quel sens
dans les tribunales
des dieux
on est associé
par la foi
à Christ
Dieu
je prends
ces représentants
légales
qui tu as
pourvus pour moi
pour que je sois
déclaré innocent
c'est lui
qui a vécu
la vie parfaite
à ma place
c'est lui
qui a souffert
la punition
que j'ai mérité
donc je me présente
devant toi
sur la base
de ses mérites
et on est
complètement accepté
pour toujours
accepter
par contre
cette union légale
elle implique
une union
vitale
avec Christ
on est comme
une branche
coupée
morte
qui a été
greffée
dans la vigne
qui est Christ
donc la vie
du Christ
coule envers nous
et nous allons
être constamment
sanctifiés
pour
les moments
où on va
déposer notre foi
en Jésus
on est déclaré
juste une fois
pour toutes
par contre
dans l'expérience
des vies chrétiennes
nous devons
revenir
constamment
à Christ
avoir conscience
de cette union
avec Christ
l'aspect
le plus aimable
de ce passage
c'est de voir
que nous
pouvons avoir
du mal
être retardés
à saisir
cette réalité
attention
nous savons
que la mesure
de notre amour
envers Christ
est faible
mais elle
sera progressive
et proportionnelle
à la compréhension
et au ressenti
de cet amour
du Christ
vers nous
voilà pourquoi
Jean
dans ce texte
n'est pas en train
de dire
nous l'aimons
car
c'est une explication
déjà
mais l'emphase
qu'il est en train
de mettre ici
maintenant
c'est
regarder comment
il nous a aimés
notre union
avec Christ
notre compréhension
de notre union
avec Christ
elle sera progressive
et proportionnelle
à la compréhension
de la manière
dont Christ
lui-même
se voit
uni à nous
et il s'est vu
tellement unis
à nous
par amour
par un amour
à l'extrême
qu'il a voulu
afficher cela
de toutes les manières
possibles
à l'extrême
y compris
en avant
les pieds
de ses disciples
mais surtout
à la croix
du calvaire
et donc
que Dieu nous donne
la grâce
que le Saint-Esprit
nous donne
la puissance
de pouvoir
comprendre
que notre foi
ne peut qu'exister
et maintenir
et qu'elle va
certainement
progresser
car les moments
où on a pu
croire
dans cette provision
parfaite
de Dieu
on a été
déjà
en train
d'être
comblés
à l'extrême
de l'amour
du Christ
envers nous
le seul pas
qu'on fait
pour
embrasser
cet amour
glorieux
c'est d'éteindre
nos mains
vides
en disant
à Dieu
voici ma foi
j'ai mes livres
je me fais
confiance
à l'amour
de Christ
envers moi
c'est le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
qui s'est uni
à nous
car à la croix
il n'était pas
en train
d'expier
les fautes
automatiques
des impénitents
de toutes les personnes
de ceux
qui rejeteraient
il était là
en train
et voilà pourquoi
il dit ça
avec toutes les paroles
vers la fin
de ces passages
je connais
ceux
qui j'ai choisi
c'est un mystère
pour nous
comment
a pu rejeter
Judas
je ne sais pas
je connais très bien
avant ma conversion
comment j'ai rejeté
les Christs
mais les jours
où j'ai eu
la moindre perception
d'un amour
salvateur
des dieux
envers moi
salvifique
je ne peux pas
attribuer cet amour
envers Christ
à quelque chose
de moi-même
c'est incompréhensible
et étonnant
pourquoi pas
les autres
on ne connait pas
les moments
les temps
où qui seront
visités
par cet amour
mais nous connaissons
très bien
les moments
où on s'est senti
aimé
d'une manière
salvatrice
par Dieu
et on sait
très bien
que ce n'était
pas grâce
à Dieu
les grands mystères
ce n'est pas
pourquoi pas
les autres
les grands mystères
c'est pourquoi
moi
pourquoi
Dieu
m'a choisi
pourquoi
Dieu
a fait
que je franchisse
avec toutes
les couches
d'incrédulité
que j'avais
envers lui
les jours
où son amour
a percé
tout mon système
pécheur défensif
contre la foi chrétienne
et il l'est fait
à travers
l'acte
de nous aimer
à l'extrême
manifesté
sur toi
croix
voici l'agneur
des dieux
qui hôte
les péchés
du monde